It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务发展迅速。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢再忙碌，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这绝对是一个不会常有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. All kids face challenges as they grow, from school pressures to friendship ruptures to family tension. While stress and setbacks are a normal part of life, giving kids the tools to manage these challenges, whether large or small, can help them cope and thrive. Today we're going to talk to a psychologist who has spent decades developing programs to help children build these essential resilience skills. So how do kids develop resilience? What role can parents, caregivers, and schools play in shaping it?
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负荷使用期间不会遭遇数据流量降速。所有孩子在成长过程中都会面临挑战，从学业压力、友谊破裂到家庭矛盾。虽然压力和挫折是生活正常的一部分，但赋予孩子们应对这些挑战（无论大小）的工具，能够帮助他们应对并茁壮成长。今天，我们将与一位心理学家进行对话，她花费了数十年时间开发旨在帮助儿童建立这些基本心理韧性技能的项目。那么，孩子们是如何培养心理韧性的呢？父母、照顾者和学校在塑造韧性方面又能发挥什么作用呢？
What the psychological research tell us about how to help children cope with disappointment, manage strong emotions, and build confidence? And how can resilience-building programs be scaled to schools and communities to reach the children who need them most? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
心理学研究为我们提供了哪些关于如何帮助儿童应对失落、管理强烈情绪以及建立自信的启示？如何将培养心理韧性的项目推广到学校和社区，以触及最需要这些帮助的孩子们？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
My guest today is Dr. Mary Alvord, a licensed psychologist with more than 40 years of clinical experience. She's the founder of Alvord Baker and Associates, a therapy practice in Maryland and Washington, D.C. She's also an adjunct associate professor in the Department of Psychiatry and Behavioral Sciences at the George Washington University School of Medicine. Dr. Alvord is an internationally recognized expert in resilience and developed the Resilience Builder Program, a group therapy program. designed to help children and teens bounce back from challenges. She also found that a nonprofit organization, Resilience Across Borders, to bring the program to students in schools. Dr. Alvord is the author of four books, including the resilience building workbooks for teens, conquer negative thinking and the action mindset. Dr. Alvord, thank you for joining me today. Thank you. I am very
我今天的嘉宾是玛丽·阿尔沃德博士（Dr. Mary Alvord），她是一位拥有 40 多年临床经验的注册心理学家。她是马里兰州和华盛顿特区治疗诊所阿尔沃德-贝克及合伙人诊所（Alvord Baker and Associates）的创始人。她还是乔治华盛顿大学医学院精神病学与行为科学系的兼职副教授。阿尔沃德博士是国际公认的心理韧性专家，并开发了“韧性建设者计划”（Resilience Builder Program），这是一个旨在帮助儿童和青少年从挑战中恢复过来的团体治疗项目。她还创立了一家名为“跨界韧性”（Resilience Across Borders）的非营利组织，将该项目带给学校的学生。阿尔沃德博士是四本书的作者，其中包括面向青少年的心理韧性建设工作手册《战胜消极思维与行动心态》。阿尔沃德博士，非常感谢您今天作客本节目。谢谢。我非常
excited to be here so that we could really help empower not just parents, but any adults that might be listening so that they can help the children in their lives and themselves. Well, let's start by talking about the word resilience. How do you define that in your research and in your clinical work? In the research, the formal definition is expanded. The traditional definition of resilience was really adapting to adversities. But in the practice and working with children and teens and families, you know, we really came to understand that it's not just, severe hardships or traumas, but resilience is being able to adapt to the stresses of daily life challenges and also the larger setbacks that we face. So we expanded it so we could include
高兴能来到这里，这样我们就能真正赋能不仅是父母，还有所有正在收听节目的成年人，帮助他们生活中的孩子以及他们自己。好吧，让我们先从“韧性”这个词开始聊起。在您的研究和临床工作中，您是如何定义它的？在研究中，正式的定义得到了扩展。韧性的传统定义实际上是对逆境的适应。但在实践中，在与儿童、青少年和家庭的合作中，你知道，我们真正开始理解，它不仅指严重的艰难困苦或创伤，韧性还是能够适应日常生活挑战的压力以及我们所面临的更大挫折。因此，我们扩展了它的定义，以便能够将
kids with ADHD or learning issues or family difficulties. Why is resilience especially important for kids today. And given your years of experience in treating children, has the need for resilience become more acute? Or are we just more aware of how hard it is to be a kid today? I think there have been so many ruptures in the last number of years, specifically some of the children have grown up starting with the pandemic, where they were not even able to go to school or were going to daycare school masked. I remember a little two-year-olds with their masks. and that created a lot of social issues as well as the stress at home at that time because parents were trying to work as well as juggling parenting and teaching and teachers were trying to
患有多动症（ADHD）、学习障碍或家庭困难的孩子包括在内。为什么心理韧性对当今的孩子尤为重要？鉴于您治疗儿童多年的经验，培养韧性的需求是否变得更加迫切？还是说我们只是更加意识到当今做一个孩子有多么不易？我认为过去几年里发生了太多的断层，特别是有些孩子从疫情开始时就一直在成长，当时他们甚至无法去学校，或者在上学时戴着口罩去日托学校。我还记得戴着口罩的两岁小宝宝们。这造成了许多社交问题，同时也带来了当时家庭中的压力，因为父母既要试图工作，又要兼顾育儿和教学，而老师们则试图
teach over video, which they had not done before. So I think it's been particularly challenging and the uncertainties of the world. We get instantaneous news as adults and that, affects adults and our moods and what we are role models for children. So whatever we're feeling, it does trickle down to them as well. Your work emphasizes skills like problem solving, emotional regulation, proactive thinking, and building social connections. Can you talk about what you see as the foundational skills that kids need to be resilient? First and foremost is that they start feeling agency or control over what they can control and what they can't because we don't expect them to be able to control all the outside forces or even what's going on at the family.
通过视频进行教学，这是他们以前没有做过的。所以我觉得这尤其具有挑战性，再加上世界的种种不确定性。作为成年人，我们能获得即时新闻，这会影响成年人以及我们的情绪，并对孩子产生榜样作用。因此，无论我们感受到什么，它也会潜移默化地影响到他们。您的工作强调了诸如问题解决、情绪调节、前瞻性思维和建立社会连接等技能。您能谈谈您认为孩子们具备韧性所需要的基础技能是什么吗？首先也是最重要的是，他们开始对能够控制和不能控制的事情产生自主权或掌控感，因为我们并不期望他们能够控制所有的外部力量，甚至无法控制家庭中正在发生的事情。
But we want them to feel empowered to make some little itty-bitty changes in their own life, which can then impact on that. And so taking initiative and more of an action mindset helps promote ability to cope as opposed to being passive and feeling helpless. So I think that's a foundational skill. What are some everyday things that parents and caregivers can do to help children build resilience? One of the factors that we know is self-regulation, being able to control your emotions, your behavior, your attention. And so not only do we model it, but we help that. We help the them calm down. First, we make sure they get enough sleep and that they're eating properly, because if we don't get enough sleep, that really unravels everybody. I mean, you see with young
但我们希望他们能够感到有能力在自己的生活中做出一些微小的改变，而这些改变反过来又能产生影响。因此，采取主动和更积极的行动心态有助于提升应对能力，而不是被动和感到无助。所以我认为这是一项基础技能。父母和照顾者可以做哪些日常事情来帮助孩子建立心理韧性？我们所了解的因素之一是自我调节，即能够控制你的情绪、你的行为、你的注意力。因此，我们不仅要以身作则，还要提供帮助。我们帮助他们平静下来。首先，我们要确保他们有充足的睡眠并且饮食得当，因为如果我们睡眠不足，那真的会让所有人都崩溃。我的意思是，你可以看到幼儿
children, they can fall apart and they might be hungry or tired, right? And so we teach them the skills. We teach them like five-finger breathing to not breathe through their chest, but when they're upset to be able to calm down and breathe through their tummies, which is sort of the natural way. But as we get older, we tend to breathe through our chest and even hyperventilate. So calmness and again as role models, we show them that. We also teach kids simple muscle relaxation, like tense your fist. Hold it, hold it, hold it, slowly relax. And you can feel a tension come out.
如果饿了或累了，他们就会情绪崩溃，对吧？所以我们教给他们技能。我们教他们像五指呼吸法，不是用胸腔呼吸，而是在他们心烦意乱时能够平静下来并通过腹部呼吸，这可以说是最自然的方式。但随着年龄的增长，我们往往会用胸腔呼吸，甚至过度换气。所以保持平静，再次强调作为榜样，我们要向他们展示这一点。我们还教孩子们简单的肌肉放松法，比如攥紧拳头。保持住，保持住，保持住，然后慢慢放松。你就能感觉到紧张感消退了。
And so we can do it with young kids by pretending they're a turtle, for example. And turtles, when they get upset, right? They clench their little legs and arms, go into their shell, bring their heads in. And so we can tense the whole body like that. And then slowly the threats are gone. Your arms and your legs can relax. A little bit older children can do it with just different muscle. group. So we can teach some very specific skills. And we actually have videos illustrating this on
所以我们可以通过让幼儿假装自己是一只乌龟来做到这一点，例如。乌龟在心烦意乱的时候，对吧？它们会收紧自己的小腿和手臂，缩进壳里，把头缩进去。所以我们可以像那样让全身紧绷。然后慢慢地，威胁消失了。你的手臂和腿就可以放松了。年龄稍大一点的孩子可以通过不同的肌肉群来做到这一点。所以我们可以教一些非常具体的技能。我们实际上有展示这些技能的视频，
the nonprofit has a website, teachresilience.org. And families can access five self-regulation videos that they can practice with their children or their teens or themselves. Yeah, I was going to say, it sounds like resilience is something that the parent, the teacher, the caregiver needs to have as well. If you yourself don't have resilience, how can you impart it to the child. Absolutely. And resiliency isn't a all or nothing. So it's not like you have resilience or you don't. You might be more resilient at certain times in your life or in certain areas. The key is to keep building it. But you're right. The more families have, the better off the children are. Because again, we model so much is communicated nonverbaly. Kids feel things. They sense
该非营利组织有一个网站：teachresilience.org。家庭可以访问五个自我调节视频，他们可以与孩子、青少年或自己一起练习。是的，我想说的是，听起来韧性不仅是孩子，也是父母、老师、照顾者需要具备的品质。如果你自己都没有韧性，又怎么能把它传授给孩子呢？绝对是这样。而且韧性不是非黑即白的。所以它不是说你要么有韧性，要么就没有。你可能在生命中的某些时刻或在某些领域表现得更有韧性。关键是要不断培养它。但你说得对。家庭拥有的韧性越多，孩子们的状态就会越好。因为同样地，我们有很多东西都是通过非语言沟通传达的。孩子们能感受到
things and what's really wonderful and what's exciting all these years for me about resilience is that we can actually learn these skills. It is not. Like Anne Mastin calls it ordinary magic, which I think is a great frame because it's not, it is reachable. We can all do it. Which leads me to the question of whether there are some kids who are just born resilient or do all children need to learn resilience? Again, it's not an all or nothing. I think there are children who are temperamentally able to calm themselves more easily than others. Some have talents and attributes that may also help them. But the bottom line is everyone can build it.
事情。他们能够感知事情，而这些年来对我来说关于韧性最美妙、最令人兴奋的事情是，我们实际上可以学习这些技能。它并不像安·马斯廷（Anne Masten）所说的“普通魔法”那样，我认为这是一个很好的框架，因为它并非遥不可及。我们所有人都能做到。这就引出了一个问题：有些孩子是否生来就很有韧性，还是所有孩子都需要学习韧性？同样，这不是非黑即白的。我认为有些孩子在气质上比其他人更容易让自己平静下来。有些人具有天赋和特质，这也可能对他们有所帮助。但底线是，每个人都可以培养韧性。
And in various areas, for example, school and academics might not be a strain. Well, hey, then we look at what other areas are you good at or even interested? So it's building assets instead of a deficit model. Like, what's wrong with you? It's like, let's build it up. So for our listeners who might be parents or teachers or just people who are working with children, how can they recognize when children are low on resilience? What should they be looking for in the way of behavior or other signals?
在不同的领域，例如学校和学业可能不是一种压力。那么，嘿，我们就会看看你在哪些其他领域擅长甚至感兴趣？所以这是在积累优势，而不是采用缺点模型，比如“你有什么毛病？”而是“让我们把它建立起来”。所以对于我们的听众来说，他们可能是父母、老师或者只是与儿童工作的人，他们该如何识别孩子韧性不足的情况呢？在行为或其他信号方面，他们应该寻找什么？
Most common behaviors are the warning signs are when suddenly there's a, a sudden change in behavior of any kind, a pattern that they've had. We also look, are they withdrawing? Are they withdrawing from family? Are they withdrawing from peers? Are they more lethargic? So we look at the behaviors to see what changes, because they don't always say, I'm sad or I'm upset verbally, but we can look for this. And I think parents who are most resilient, are also really good at tuning in to their children, as well as teachers who can tune in to the children who might seem quiet and doing fine, but there are these more subtle, nuanced signs to look for.
最常见的行为或危险信号是当突然出现任何形式的行为改变、偏离了他们原有的模式时。我们还会观察，他们是否在退缩？他们是否在疏离家庭？他们是否在疏离同龄人？他们是否变得更加冷漠？所以我们通过观察行为来看看有什么变化，因为他们并不总是会用言语说出“我很伤心”或“我很沮丧”，但我们可以寻找这些迹象。我认为最有韧性的父母，同时也非常擅长敏锐地关注他们的孩子，老师也是如此，他们能够关注到那些看起来安静且表现不错的孩子，但其实存在着这些更微妙、更细腻的迹象需要去寻找。
And say your kid decides one day, I don't want to go to school anymore. You know, I mean, there could be those kinds of reactions where the child is telling you something. What do you as the parent do to try to pro? and understand where that's coming from and then give the kid the tools to be able to confront whatever it is, say, at school that is giving them stress. You said it accurately in terms of what at school might be giving them stress. And so as parents, we learn to listen and reflect back and not judgmentally say, you have to go to school. You know, you really want to probe and have a conversation with sometimes kids don't want to go to school, go to school.
假设你的孩子有一天突然决定：“我再也不想去上学了。”你知道，我的意思是，可能会出现那种反应，孩子在向你传达某些信息。作为父母，你会怎么做去尝试探究并理解这背后的原因，然后给孩子提供工具去面对学校里带给他压力的任何事情？你在“学校里可能是什么带给他压力”这一点上表达得很准确。所以作为父母，我们学会倾听并进行回应，而不是用批判的语气说“你必须去上学”。你知道，你真的需要去探究并进行对话，有时候孩子们不想去上学，不去学校
school because they worry about doing something wrong or they've had a problem with a friend or so many different things. And I'm wondering, you know, what's going on when you go to school? I also at the same time say, what's going well when you're at school? So we don't want to just focus on all the what's going not well because we're going to use what's going well to get them back to school quickly because we don't want it to turn into a school avoidance problem. We really do want to figure out, you know, what is the avoidance? You know, I'll just say this here. I don't believe that kids are lazy, you know, here's a co. You know, I would hear, oh, he's just lazy is not doing it. No, it may be that it's hard. And what we've found out in the practice is that sometimes learning is
是因为他们担心做错事，或者他们和朋友出了问题，或者有太多不同的事情。我在想，“你知道，当你去学校时到底发生了什么？”与此同时，我也会问：“你在学校时有什么事情进展顺利？”所以我们不想只关注所有进展不顺利的事情，因为我们要利用那些进展顺利的事情让他们尽快回到学校，因为我们不希望这演变成学校回避问题。我们确实想弄清楚，你知道，究竟回避的是什么？你知道，我在这里直说吧。我不认为孩子们是懒惰的，你知道，这是一种。你知道，我经常听到，“哦，他只是懒，所以不去做。”不，可能原因是这很难。我们在实践中发现，有时学习
hard for some kids and they're not, and they're feeling bad about it. But they're not saying it. But they're doing enough that it's not being picked up on by the teachers, but in terms of their own set of expectations, they feel bad. You we hear a lot these days about grit being something that helps kids succeed. Is there a difference between resilience and grit? How are the two concepts related if they are? Some people use them interchangeably. There are differences. Angela Duckworth has define grid as perseverance, sticking to goals, and resilience is really a broad set of skills. So it would encompass sticking to things and feeling like you have the capacity and the ability to do it. You know, I can try. I can keep doing this. I can do it better. So I think resilience
对某些孩子来说很难，他们做不到，并且为此感到难过。但他们没有说出来。然而他们的表现又没有差到被老师发现的程度，但在他们自己的期望标准下，他们感到很难过。现在我们经常听到“坚毅”（grit）是帮助孩子取得成功的一种品质。韧性和坚毅之间有什么区别？如果这两个概念有关联，它们是如何联系的？有些人会交替使用这两个概念。它们是有区别的。安吉拉·达克沃斯（Angela Duckworth）将坚毅定义为毅力、坚持目标，而韧性则是一组广泛的技能。因此，它将包括坚持做事情，并觉得自己有能力和潜力去完成它。“我能尝试。我能继续做下去。我能做得更好。”所以我认为韧性
from at least my vantage point is a little bit broader. But it's certainly incredible. incorporates grit as well as other terms that have been used like hardiness, which is really, you know, seeing challenges as opportunities and not as dead ends, you know, and that's where the problem solving comes in and the perspective comes in. And that's all part of what we teach when we teach resilience skills. So speaking of teaching resilience skills, how should adults respond when they see kids who are struggling or failing. I mean, what kinds of reactions are going to support resilience and what kinds are going to undermine it? Understanding what are barriers for them, like what's getting in the way? So a standard question I have is, what's getting in the way of you
从我的角度来看，至少要稍微广泛一些。但它当然也包含了坚毅，以及其他一些曾被使用的术语，比如“坚韧”（hardiness），这实际上是指（你知道的）将挑战视为机遇而不是死胡同，这就是问题解决发挥作用的地方，也是视角发挥作用的地方。而这正是我们教授韧性技能时所传授的内容的一部分。所以说到教授韧性技能，当成年人看到苦苦挣扎或遭遇失败的孩子时，应该如何回应？我的意思是，什么样的反应能够支持韧性，什么样的反应会破坏韧性？理解对他们来说什么是障碍，比如是什么在阻碍他们？所以我有一个标准的问题是：“是什么在阻碍你
doing X, Y, or Z, you know, and it's not just school. It might be they don't want to engage in sports because perhaps they're afraid of failing so they don't even want to try. You know, we call that like all or nothing thinking. You're either you're perfect at it, which there is no such thing as perfect, or you're fantastic. And so we try as parents, as teachers, to help them understand sort of modulated, realistic thinking. It's looking at what is getting in the way and what is. helps them overcome. Because again, we're always balancing understanding and listening for and watching for signs where kids are not able to do something with at the same time what they are able to do.
做 X、Y 或 Z？”你知道，这不仅限于学校。可能是他们不想参加体育运动，因为他们可能害怕失败，所以甚至不想尝试。你知道，我们称之为“非黑即白的思维”。你要么在上面表现得完美（而根本没有完美这回事），要么你就得表现得非常棒。因此，作为父母、作为老师，我们试图帮助他们理解这种经过调节的、现实的思考方式。它关注的是什么在阻碍他们，以及是什么在帮助他们克服困难。因为同样地，我们总是在平衡理解、倾听并观察孩子无法做到某事的迹象，以及他们同时能够做到什么。
Is there a role for technology when it comes to building resilience in kids? The way I see it is that many platforms can allow practice of skills. Now, technology, is a tool. And we won't go into all of the privacy issues, the concerns that may be there for safety. But as a tool, well done, it can be used to practice. We actually use technology to, for kids who are selectively mute or very shy or socially anxious, for them to practice speaking a little bit louder, making the eye contact and getting that feedback, why, Watching videos, which is a simple technology now, right, as opposed to a platform. Practicing texting, because that is a way that most teens nowadays communicate. They don't call each other on the phone as much. They tend to text or, you know, have other means through different platforms that they're using. So I think monitored and in balance it can be used because we know
在培养孩子的韧性方面，科技能发挥作用吗？在我看来，许多平台可以让人练习技能。现在，科技是一个工具。我们不会深入探讨所有隐私问题、可能存在的安全隐患。但作为一个工具，如果运用得当，它可以用来进行练习。我们实际上利用科技来帮助那些选择性缄默、非常害羞或有社交焦虑的孩子，让他们练习大一点声说话、进行眼神交流并获得反馈。为什么呢？观看视频（这现在是一项简单的技术，对吧，而不是某个平台）。练习发短信，因为那是当今大多数青少年沟通的方式。他们不再经常给对方打电话了。他们倾向于发短信，或者通过他们正在使用的不同平台进行其他方式的交流。所以我认为在监控和保持平衡的情况下，它是可以被使用的，因为我们知道
practicing skills makes them better that doesn't make them perfect because we're not trying to achieve perfection, but practice can make things better. So if you have a platform, you know, we can use it. A moment ago, you mentioned the pandemic and the problems that it sort of instilled in all of us as we had to deal with isolation and so forth. Are kids bouncing back since the pandemic ended? I think so. You know, I know there were some concerned about, academic lags. But I think at this point, a few years later, it is important for families to engage kids socially in person and balance with activities. And I think the academics, hopefully schools are in tune so that they can really get kids up to par if they have fallen behind. We talk about stress and depression and anxiety increasing.
练习技能会让他们变得更好，这虽然不会让他们变得完美，因为我们并不是在追求完美，但练习可以使事情变得更好。所以如果你有一个平台，你知道，我们可以使用它。刚才，你提到了疫情以及它在我们所有人不得不应对隔离等情况时灌输给我们的问题。自从疫情结束后，孩子们的状态有反弹吗？我想是的。我知道有些人对学业滞后表示担忧。但我认为在这一点上，几年过去了，重要的是家庭要让孩子们在现实生活中进行社交活动，并与各种活动保持平衡。而且我认为学业方面，希望学校能够跟上节奏，以便在孩子们落后时真正让他们赶上来。我们谈到压力、抑郁和焦虑在增加。
We're also better at diagnosing these things. So again, it's has everything gotten worse or are we just better at identification in many cases and identifying perhaps what are the lags, what are the absence of some skills and penetrating it. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Alvord about how she and her colleagues are bringing resilience building programs to schools and classrooms. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499.
我们在诊断这些问题上也变得更好了。所以同样地，究竟是一切都变得更糟了，还是我们在许多情况下只是更擅长识别了，并且能更好地识别可能存在的滞后、某些技能的缺失并进行干预。我们要进行短暂的休息。休息回来后，我将与阿尔沃德博士谈谈她和她的同事们是如何将韧性建设程序引入学校和课堂的。你的夏天从全国家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日特惠开始。是时候用 Nextgrill 四火眼燃气烧烤炉开启夏日烧烤派对了，特惠价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用汉普顿湾（Hampton Bay）韦斯特格罗夫（West Grove）七件套户外用餐套装招待亲友，仅需 499 美元。
This Memorial Day get low-priced. is guaranteed at the Home Depot. Lost supplies last. Price in valid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save?
在这个阵亡将士纪念日，尽享低价。在家得宝即可享受价格保证。售完即止。价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，适用除外条款。详情请参见 Home Depot.com/pricematch。你之前说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路在哪。我们省了多少钱？
Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your ocean front room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected.
够了。够去迷路的了。或者你可以预订希尔顿的住宿。欢迎来到您的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订，最高可省 20%，获得您期待的住宿体验。
When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Let's talk about your resilience builder program and your nonprofit organization, Resilience Across Borders. So these are used to bring your tools into schools. How does that work?
当您想要省钱而不是惊吓时。您住哪里很重要。希尔顿，伴您好梦。让我们来谈谈您的“韧性建设者计划”以及您的非营利组织“跨界韧性”。那么，这些被用来将您的工具引入学校。它是如何运作的？
How many schools are using the program? And what does it look like in everyday use? We were doing the Resilience Builder program, which is a small group program in the practice since 1992, so for many years. And we did research on that and found positive outcomes. We decided we wanted to scale it. And with the founding of the nonprofit, we are going into economically marginalized schools first. and we did a five-year randomized control trial in a fairly large school system in the D.C. area. We had, I think, at that point, several hundred children that participated in the research because it was small group.
有多少学校在使用该程序？在日常使用中它是什么样的？我们自 1992 年以来一直在实践中开展“韧性建设者计划”——这是一个小型团体项目，所以已经很多年了。我们对此进行了研究，并发现了积极的成果。我们决定将其规模化。随着该非营利组织的成立，我们首先进入了经济边缘化的学校。我们在华盛顿特区地区一个相当大的学系进行了一项为期五年的随机对照试验。我们在研究中让数百名儿童参与其中，因为它是小型的团体形式。
We had to end the research, but fortunately, we had five years in, so it was, okay, we had enough data right when the pandemic started. And we got amazing results. I mean, we were targeting resilience, but we also found not only did they have a better sense of self-mastery and agency over their life, control over some things, but they also increased academic motivation and classroom engagement, you know, personal skills and study skills. So that made our hearts sing because, you know, we weren't targeting those specifically, but it made a lot of sense. Because if you increase your capacity and you feel like you're in more control of your life, then you're more willing to take risks. And classrooms are risk, speaking up, you know, making a mistake. All of those are risks. And then actually right before the pandemic, one of the principals said, you know, this is a mistake.
我们不得不结束这项研究，但幸运的是，我们已经进行了五年，所以这没问题，在疫情爆发时我们恰好收集到了足够的数据。我们取得了惊人的成果。我的意思是，我们的目标是培养韧性，但我们不仅发现他们对自己生活的掌控感和自主权增强了、对某些事情的控制力提高了，而且他们的学业动机、课堂参与度、个人技能和学习技能也有所提升。这让我们欢欣鼓舞，因为，你知道的，我们并没有专门针对这些方面，但这非常合情合理。因为如果你提升了自己的能力，并且觉得对生活的掌控力更强了，那么你就更愿意承担风险。而课堂就是一种风险：发言、犯错。所有这些都是风险。就在疫情爆发前不久，其中一位校长说：“你知道，这太
great. We're actually seeing behavioral changes in kids based on the program, but I don't want it just for these small groups. I would like all the classrooms to get. So we've adapted a group from Alvord Baker and Resilience Cross Borders and Catholic University. We adapted the original resilience builder program so that teachers could lead. First, what we did, though, is we surveyed teachers to ask them, what's realistic? Like, how much time could you devote to a program like this? What would you want? And what do you think families could use? So they said videos would be great, short videos, activities, some handouts. And the parent component, which is what we did with the original Resilience Builder program, newsletters for parents to teach them what the skills are. So we also hired a media specialist who could target fifth grade, which is where we started, books, that would correspond to the lessons. So the newsletters for parents, which are, or families, which are free and also on the teachresilience.org website, there's 12 of them. They're in English and Spanish to also increase more access.
棒了。我们实际上看到孩子们因为这个项目而在行为上发生了改变，但我不仅希望这些小群体能参与。我希望所有的教室都能获得它。”因此，我们从阿尔沃德-贝克诊所、“跨界韧性”组织和美国天主教大学（Catholic University）调整了最初的韧性建设者计划，以便老师们能够主导。不过，我们首先做的是调查老师，询问他们：“什么才是现实可行的？比如，你能为一个这样的项目投入多少时间？你想要什么？你认为家庭能用到什么？”所以他们说视频会很好，短视频、活动、一些讲义。还有家长的部分，这正是我们通过最初的韧性建设者计划所做的，即为家长提供简报以教给他们这些技能。因此，我们还聘请了一位媒体专家，他可以针对五年级（我们开始的年级）制作与课程相对应的书籍。因此，面向家长或家庭的简报是免费的，也可以在 teachresilience.org 网站上找到，共有 12 份。它们有英语和西班牙语版本，以进一步扩大获取渠道。
And again, last year we went into a different school system. And we got results of kids showing that they, it was a short questionnaire for children and fifth graders, but we also have expanded this year to fourth graders. And hopefully we'll expand a little bit more and then do some longitudinal data as well eventually. But the questions are about, you know, do they feel they can adapt to changes and can they handle difficulties? And the pilot results were statistically significant, for those of you who care about the data, showed that. And also teachers, again, found that academic motivation and classroom engagement and interpersonal skills increased. Now, this year, we're doing fourth and fifth grade in, I think about eight schools with almost six,
同样，去年我们进入了一个不同的学系。我们得到了孩子们表现出他们能够适应变化、能够应对困难的结果，这是针对儿童和五年级学生的一份简短问卷，但今年我们也将其扩展到了四年级。希望我们未来还能进一步扩展，并最终进行一些纵向数据研究。但这些问题关于，你知道的，他们是否觉得自己能够适应变化以及他们能否应对困难？初步结果具有统计学意义，对于那些关心数据的人来说，结果显示了这一点。此外，老师们再次发现，学业动机、课堂参与度和人际交往能力都有所提高。今年，我们正在大约八所学校的四年级和五年级开展，大约有近六百人、
almost 700 children. The ones who participate in the research and their whole classes get, the classes are randomly assigned. So everyone gets the program, even if you didn't sign up for the research. And if you're a control group, you get it in the spring. So we wanted to make sure that everyone has access to all these skills. And again, we are training teachers and they are 25, 15-minute lessons. So it's broken down so it's doable with videos, activities, and then the 12 topics have the parent, family, caregiver newsletters, and the self-regulation videos are also available to them. So we try to do a multimedia, even with the videos, we tried to make them diverse so all kids could see themselves in there.
近七百名儿童。参与研究的人和他们的整个班级都会获得该项目，班级是随机分配的。因此每个人都能参与这个项目，即使你没有报名参加研究。如果你属于对照组，你将在春季获得它。所以我们要确保每个人都能接触到所有这些技能。同样，我们正在对老师进行培训，共有 25 节 15 分钟的课程。因此，它被分解得很易于操作，配合有视频、活动，然后这 12 个主题配有家长、家庭、照顾者的简报，自我调节视频也对他们开放。所以我们尝试采用多媒体形式，甚至在视频方面，我们也努力做到多元化，以便所有的孩子都能在其中看到自己的影子，
not just skin color and hairstyle, but eyeglasses, wheelchairs. And then we made the fonts so that children with any reading disabilities or reading difficulties, they're compatible for them as well. So it sounds like you're focusing largely on elementary school-age children at this point. Is that correct? That is correct in terms of the research. And what we call the resilience builder program universal. because we started with that group and particularly fifth grade because that's such a pivotal year before they go into middle school.
不仅仅是肤色和发型，还有眼镜、轮椅。然后我们调整了字体，以便任何有阅读障碍或阅读困难的儿童也能兼容。听起来你目前主要关注的是小学年龄段的儿童。是这样的吗？就研究而言，确实如此。这就是我们所说的“通用版韧性建设者计划”。因为我们从这个群体开始，尤其是五年级，因为这是他们升入初中前的一个极其关键的节点。
So we really wanted to target that and now scaling down to fourth grade. But my writings, my workbooks are really geared toward teens because I want to give them those same skills and help them as well. It's harder to do some of the research in teachers and elementary schools. You know, the classes are more cohesive. And middle school, you get about eight different teachers. But we move into that because the resilience skills are really universal. I want to put out a shout out. APA actually has on the website that's called Building Student Resilience.
所以我们真的很想针对这个年龄段，现在正在向下扩展到四年级。但我的著作、我的工作手册真正面向的是青少年，因为我想把同样的技能传授给他们，并同样帮助他们。要在老师和小学生中进行某些研究要困难一些。你知道，小学的班级凝聚力更强。而在初中，你大约会遇到八位不同的老师。但我们会向那个方向推进，因为韧性技能确实是通用的。我想在这里特别提一下，APA（美国心理学协会）实际上在网站上有一个名为“培养学生韧性”（Building Student Resilience）的板块。
And several of us during the pandemic, and then we updated it last six months ago, put out lessons for teachers, but parents can tap into it as well. It's free. And they are different skills of resilience as well. So all you have to do is go to the APA website, search building student resilience, and it'll give you a little mini-curriculum. And it's for high school as well as elementary. How does it work within the curriculum? I mean, does a teacher say, okay, kids, and now we're going to talk about resilience? I mean, it's not really a topic like math or English or history. So how do you work it in? Some schools have social emotional learning built in. Other teachers say, and they do use the word resilience, you know, we're going to do a resilience lesson. Or we have framed some of this in terms of leadership skills. because some of the kids have been more, and some of the families have been reluctant,
在疫情期间，以及六个月前我们对其进行了更新，我们中的几个人为老师发布了课程，但家长也可以利用它。它是免费的。其中也包含不同的韧性技能。所以你只需要访问 APA 网站，搜索“培养学生韧性”，它就会为你提供一个微型课程。它既适用于高中，也适用于小学。它在课程中是如何运作的？我的意思是，老师会说：“好了，孩子们，现在我们要讨论韧性了吗？”我的意思是，它其实不像数学、英语或历史那样是一个学科。那么你是如何将它融入进去的呢？有些学校内置了社交情感学习。其他老师则会说，他们确实会使用“韧性”这个词，比如“我们要上一节韧性课”。或者我们将其中一些内容构架为领导力技能。
but we also try to teach everybody what resilience means, and that's a positive growth, as well as leadership. So the teachers introduce it. There's the first video is, what is resilience and why is it important? And it's three minutes so that they can really understand what it is and how can they build the muscles of resilience. And we really frame it that way, building the muscles of resilience. You know, you have to build, you have to eat and sleep to build your physical muscles and do exercise. Well, you can also build your muscles of coping with problems or challenges that you face, small ones or big ones or ones in between. Can you tell us a little bit about your personal story? I mean, what drew you to the topic of children and resilience?
因为有些孩子和家庭一开始比较抗拒，但我们也试图向每个人传授韧性意味着什么，这是一种积极的成长，以及领导力。所以老师们会进行介绍。第一个视频是：“什么是韧性，为什么它很重要？”它有三分钟长，这样他们就能真正理解它是什么以及如何建立韧性的肌肉。我们确实是以这种方式来构建它的——建立韧性的肌肉。你知道的，你必须通过饮食和睡眠来建立你的身体肌肉并进行锻炼。同样的，你也可以建立你应对问题或面临的挑战的肌肉，无论是小挑战、大挑战还是介于两者之间的挑战。能跟我们讲讲你的个人故事吗？我的意思是，是什么吸引你关注儿童和韧性这个话题？
Well, I have been a child and adolescent psychologist from the beginning. I just, I love children. I love the fact that they are malleable and can change. What prompted the specific resilience was in the 1980s, going back then. I was asked to give talks on strength-based curriculum and strategies. And what we discovered, particularly then, a lot of children were being adopted from Eastern Europe and having a lot of difficulties. And so I was giving many, many talks to parents in terms of how they could build. My personal story is that my parents and grandparents were actually born in Russia. And I grew up speaking Russian at home. My maternal grandfather was imprisoned. by Stalin as a capitalist, but they were able to leave.
嗯，我从一开始就是一名儿童和青少年心理学家。我只是、我热爱孩子。我喜欢他们具有可塑性并且能够改变的事实。促使我关注特定韧性的契机是在 20 世纪 80 年代，回溯到那个时候。我被邀请就基于优势的课程和策略做演讲。我们当时发现，特别是在那个时候，许多儿童从东欧被收养，并遇到了很多困难。因此，我向父母做了非常多的演讲，关于他们如何能够建立。我的个人故事是，我的父母和祖父母实际上出生在俄罗斯。我是在家里说俄语长大的。我的外祖父曾被
And they went to Iran, which was very different, new language, completely different culture. But there was an Armenian community that people helped each other acclimate. But still, it was a huge shock. And then in the 1940s, before I was born, they came to the United States. But we retained the Russian language. So when children were adopted from Russia in the early 90s, I started working with many of them and framing it as, yes, maybe they're coming with difficult, some very extreme, especially in the beginning, including like orthopedic problems and, you know, many challenges. Let's, let's build what they have because they're survivors. And I think watching my family go through having to leave everything in a country, go to another country that was completely different, learn the language, you know, get jobs.
斯大林以资本家的名义关押，但他们得以离开。他们去了伊朗，那里非常不同，有着新语言、完全不同的文化。但那里有一个亚美尼亚社区，大家互相帮助适应。然而，这仍然是一个巨大的震撼。然后在 20 世纪 40 年代，在我出生之前，他们来到了美国。但我们保留了俄罗斯语言。所以在 90 年代初从俄罗斯收养儿童时，我开始与他们中的许多人合作，并将其构建为：是的，也许他们带着困难而来，有些非常极端，尤其是在刚开始的时候，包括骨科问题和许多挑战。让我们、让我们建立他们所拥有的优势，因为他们是幸存者。我想看着我的家人经历不得不离开一个国家的全部、前往另一个完全不同的国家、学习语言、找到工作。
And then again, a third time, having to come to this country. And but they were seeking the freedom that, you know, the United States offered and were happy. But it took a toll on the family. So, you know, I think I was inspired by that. And I was also inspired by seeing all these children who were adopted coming to a land where their new families didn't speak the language that they spoke and adapting and thriving. Do you know how many kids you've reached with the program so far? Do you have a ballpark? So this year it'll be 7,800.
然后又是第三次，不得不来到这个国家。但他们一直在寻找美国所提供的自由，并且感到快乐。但这给家庭带来了沉重的代价。所以，你知道，我认为我受到了启发。我也受到看到所有这些被收养的儿童来到这片土地上的启发，他们的养父母不会说他们所说的语言，但他们却能适应并蓬勃发展。你知道到目前为止这个项目已经帮助了多少孩子吗？你大概有个估算吗？所以今年将达到 7,800 名。
Last year was about 6,700 because we also are in two. after-school programs in D.C. That they're not doing research. And prior to that, it was about five, so a few thousand. And we hope to reach more. The other aspect of this is I do trainings and on resilience for different school systems. So during the pandemic, I did many trainings for West Virginia school system, for example. And they've incorporated the resilience builder program.
去年大约是 6,700 名，因为我们还在华盛顿特区参与了两个课外项目。他们没有参与研究。在此之前，大约是五千，所以有几千人。我们希望能够触及更多人。另一个方面是，我为不同的学校系统开展关于韧性的培训。所以在疫情期间，例如，我为西弗吉尼亚州的学校系统做了许多培训。他们已经将韧性建设者计划纳入其中。
So we don't have numbers, but in terms of what we have impacted, it's several thousand. And we know it's also been done abroad in Portugal, Singapore. So it's a universal concept that can be brought universally to everyone, children, teens, and adults alike. So just to wrap up, what's next for resilience across borders and any research that you might still be doing? So the research now is the randomized control trial. We'll be wrapping that up in February, although the kids will still be receiving the program until the end of the year. And next steps are either to scale down to a little lower grade
所以我们虽然没有具体的总数，但就我们所产生的影响而言，已有数千人。而且我们知道它也在葡萄牙、新加坡等国外开展。所以这是一个通用的概念，可以普遍带给每个人——儿童、青少年和成年人。所以总结一下，“跨界韧性”组织的下一步计划是什么？还有你可能仍在进行的任何研究？所以现在的研究就是那个随机对照试验。我们将在 2 月份结束它，尽管孩子们仍将继续接受该项目直到年底。下一步是向下扩展到一个较低的年级，
and or do longitudinal data. As far as the nonprofit goes, we really want to reach out further, do trainings to teachers. hopefully at some point to actually incorporate it in teacher education, like before they become teachers. So it's part of something that they are familiar with and comfortable with. And trainings for professionals as well, as well as writing, you know,
以及/或者开展纵向数据研究。至于这个非营利组织，我们真正希望做的是进一步扩展，对老师进行培训，希望在某个时候将其真正纳入教师教育中，比如在他们成为教师之前。这样它就成为他们熟悉且感到舒适的一部分。同时也对专业人士进行培训，并且进行写作，
with Catholic University and the research team at Alvord Baker, we publish in professional peer-reviewed journals. I've written a couple of chapters as well. so disseminating to professionals, but my heart is mostly in terms of disseminating to the public. So these skills can reach everyone's lives. Well, Dr. Alvord, I want to thank you so much for joining me today. It's been very interesting. Thank you so much for having me.
与天主教大学以及阿尔沃德-贝克的研发团队合作，我们在专业的同行评审期刊上发表文章。我也写过好几个章节。所以向专业人士传播是一方面，但我的心主要还是在于向公众传播。这样这些技能就能走进每个人的生活。好吧，阿尔沃德博士，非常感谢你今天能来。节目非常精彩。非常感谢邀请我。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery store.
您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方收听往期的《心理学谈话》。如果您喜欢我们所分享的内容，请关注我们并留下评价。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以通过电子邮件联系我们：speakingofpsychology@APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦内曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯。放松一下，让克罗格（Ralphs）的配送服务来处理您本周的杂货
shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes, so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
采购吧。我们从最新鲜的商品开始，然后查看您的清单并仔细挑选每一件。接着我们会将它们打包好，并在短短 30 分钟内送达，让您确信这就是您所订购的商品。新鲜杂货，尽在您的掌控，尽在克罗格的配送与自提服务。现在，您的首次配送或自提订单即可立省 20 美元。克罗格，为您呈现新鲜。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。